hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einem neuen
video amerika hat einen neuen
präsidenten und ich würde in diesem
video gar nicht sagen ob ich ihn gut
finde oder den schlecht finde sondern
einfach ein verfahren über den sagen die
ich mir im internet zusammen gesucht
haben bevor ich mit den fakten anfangen
möchte ich euch aber noch ganz kurz
sagen leute ich stehe nicht auf der
seite von hillary clinton auch nicht auf
der seite von donald trump für mich war
dieser wahlkampf einer der schmutzigsten
und bescheuerten wahlkämpfe den die usa
je gesehen hat also will ich aber auch
nicht partei ergreifen ich finde das war
not gegen elend dieses jahr und ich bin
aber trotzdem donald trump ist jetzt
präsident geworden man sollte einfach
abwarten ich glaube sein abends andere
ist am 20 januar nächsten jahres
abwarten und jetzt fangen wir mit den
fakten
das britische parlament hat mal darüber
debattiert ob es donald trump in zukunft
erlaubt sein soll nach großbritannien
einreisen zu dürfen nämlich über seine
petition 250.000 unterschriften
gesammelt von leuten die das nicht
wollen
donald trumps fortfahren stammen aus
deutschland das heißt er ist halt
deutscher wald fahren wollte im jahr
2000 schon mal präsident werden war
allerdings für eine reformpartei und
nicht wie jetzt bei den republikanern
angesiedelt und er hat es nicht
geschafft er hat es aber schon mal
versucht
donald trump besitzt eine so genannten
tram plaza in new jersey und hat dort
schon oftmals www veranstaltungen
ausgetragen
sind so methling events oder hat auch
schon ein paar mal daran teilgenommen
trumps vermögen beträgt 3,7 milliarden
us dollar
viel zu viel rummel 2 bis 70 jahre alt
allerdings ist eine frau 46
warum die den wohl hat enel spa ist ein
sogenannter german pop es hat nichts mit
germany oder so zu tun sondern das heißt
einfach dass seine abneigung gegenüber
dreck und schmutzig kite hat und er
vertraut auf das händeschütteln ich
glaube als präsident schönste ca 4
milliarden händler im jahr einen preis
bekommen als schlechtester
nebendarsteller in dem film ghost kann
durch also nicht mal spielen kann
er trinkt keinen alkohol weil sein
bruder an alkoholismus gestorben ist
aber solid schwarm hat seinen eigenen
wodka namens trump wort gab obwohl der
liebe gelernt habe überhaupt keinen
tropfen alkohol trinkt donald trump hat
mal ein spiel raus gebracht bei dem man
versuchen kann so wie er enorm schnell
an enorm viel geld ranzukommen
allerdings war das spiel ein totaler
flop
weil auch klar sondern schwamm verhaftet
dass er sich seit der ersten
grundschulklasse überhaupt nicht mehr
verändert hat was ein temperament und
seine personalien angeht und so kommt
für mich auch rüber freibad mal in ein
interview mit conan o'brien in einer
talkshow gesagt dass er selbst
noch nie meine tm genutzt hat also noch
nie geld von einem geldautomaten
abgehoben hat aber ich glaube auch
ehrlich gesagt dass er leute hat die das
für ihn übernehmen
der trump tower in new york wurde von
200 polnischen arbeitskräften aufgebaut
die alle lose vier bis fünf dollar pro
stunde verdient haben und teilweise
zwölf stunden am tag arbeiten mussten
was natürlich höchstgradig illegal ist
aber schwamm streitet das die ganze zeit
ab
donald schwabe war 2004 ein haus von
einer tv-serie die ultra bekam bei den
leuten und deswegen hat er auch einen
stern auf dem hollywood walk of fame
bekommen
allerdings haben in den letzten wochen
während des wahlkampfes einige leute
verschiedene politische aktivitäten an
diesem stern ausgeübt also ich werde
euch mal hier ein paar bilder ein
es sind letzte fakt verholzte donald
trump es ab dem 20 januar nächsten
jahres der 45 präsident der vereinigten
staaten von amerika schon krass das
heißt hier mit dem fast meine damen und
herren kumpel von mir ist gerade selber
in amerika und war auch in new york hat
diese ganze wahl sache mitbekommen
er hat mir halt whatsapp geschrieben das
ist da gerade richtig krass ist und ich
habe dann halt gefragt wenn das da so
krass ab geht da meinte er war gestern
noch relativ lang auf den straßen
unterwegs
es sind so viele leute auf den straßen
demonstriert haben fassungslos weinend
vor den anzeigen standen ist schon
heftig aber ich meine er ist erst ab dem
20 januar wirklich in seinen abend drin
und was anderes als abwarten können wir
jetzt eh nicht machen aber ich habe mir
gedacht ist sind so viele sachen gerade
im internet so übels negativ sind alle
haben angst deswegen sagen wir einfach
mal 15 16 17 fakten einfach mal ein paar
infos über donald trump jetzt nicht
wirklich was mit der ganzen politik
sache derzeit zu tun haben sondern halt
ihre sachen gesagt die beispielsweise
mit seiner talkshow oder dass er es
hasst hände zu schütteln das heißt wenn
ihr jetzt noch dran sein freunde und
euch wirklich dieses video bis zehn
werde angeguckt hat dann schreibt mal
donnell schwan kunden in die kommentare
da sehe ich ja dass ihr das ganze bis
zum ende geschaut hat und sonst würde
ich sagen sehen uns in einem anderen
video wieder ich hoffe ich konnte euch
unterhalten und leute schild einfach wie
obama schon gesagt hat die sonne am
nächsten morgen wir trotzdem noch
aufgehen also kriegen wir schon hin